it's time for tonight's hashtag war
this may not come as any surprise to you
but this year's presidential nominees
are the least popular of all time one of
the main things people are saying is
that they're gonna be voting for the
lesser of two evils but if you over the
lesser of two evils we still end up with
an evil but there have to be better
reasons for electing the next president
of our United States of America that's
why tonight's hashtag is I'm voting
because and it's very important you to
get out and vote you need to get out and
vote or you can't complain right as
Americans to bitch as long as you vote
as long as you vote you can bitch all
you want so examples might be I want to
feel superior to teens or I'm gonna use
that I voted sticker discover a scar I
put 60 seconds on the clock and begin
Jonathan I'm voting because I look like
this all right points points Jonathan I
voted because if I don't my 12 years of
slave screenplay book club would be very
upset with all right points I heard 3k
and I voted sticker gets you in the
Hamilton all right points I'm voting
because feminism is a new patriarchy and
I'm here for all right points because
there's a difference between unpopular
and evil all right I'm voting because
these fingers are not for picking
different rolling okay
gentlemen I'm voting because I Tuesday
off okay I'm voting because my Mexican
mechanic said he'd give me a deal all
right boys I like saying I did a civic
duty yes